je m'appelle Olivier decaze je suis le
fondateur de l'officine du monde qui est
une marque de complément alimentaire et
cosmétique à base de nigelle mes bureaux
sont situés à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'entreprise a été créée en avril 2021
[Musique]
c'est une plante ancestrale qu'on
consomme au quotidien depuis plus de
3000 ans notamment à Babylone on en a
retrouvé dans la tombe de Toutankhamon
appartient aux plantes qui sont
recommandées en usage quotidien pour le
bien-être la santé et les soins
cosmétiques et capillaires depuis plus
de 1300 ans
[Musique]
il se trouve que je viens de l'univers
des cosmétiques et des grands groupes
français de la cosmétique et au cours
d'un voyage à Dubaï j'ai entendu parler
de cette plante et j'ai entrevue assez
rapidement ça résonance mythique j'ai
cherché une personne qui connaissent
parfaitement la Niger c'est là que j'ai
rencontré la personne qui allait devenir
mon associé qui est une pharmacie
française diplômée de Paris-Saclay mais
aussi égyptienne franco-egyptienne et
l'idée ça a été donc de développer une
gamme de haute qualité
[Musique]
nous avons quatre sources de nigelle
nous avons une nigelle qui vient d'Inde
nous en avons une qui vient d'Éthiopie
d'Égypte ou de Tunisie d'où la
transformons en France nous la
conditionnons
[Musique]
nous avons trois gammes une gamme que
nous appelons indispensables une gamme
santé et une gamme ou nous avons que des
huiles nous sommes dans un certain
nombre de pharmacies nous sommes dans 11
pharmacies aujourd'hui un peu dans toute
la France à Lille en banlieue parisienne
les au-delà de la France nous avons un
projet qui a vocation allait à
l'international